how much should a filmmaker pay
themselves
whatever they can i mean you know at the
end of the day
it depends you know when i say filmmaker
i think about me
i'm involved concept to delivery you
know i just got into it with somebody
the other day who worked on our last
film and they worked i think
four to six weeks on break even i just
celebrated my 27th month on the film
last week
now we lost five months of covid but
during the covet time we had to
repurpose our distribution outlets
what we were going to do so i ended up
dealing with a whole new list of
deliverables
a whole new group of people with
different qc demands you know for
quality control for release
so you know there are people on that
film that worked
three or four weeks i got paid a hell of
a lot more than i did and
you know here i am i'm literally like
almost two and a half years in and i
wouldn't change a thing about it i don't
do it for the money i do it because i
love
to do it i i just i enjoy the process
but you know i always say be fair
you're going to have an investor that
you want to be able to have an open
books relationship with if you have an
investor that says i'd like to see the
books
you don't want to that's not a good
position to be in there are plenty of
people you can google in hollywood who
have
gone to prison um i always say just
when you hand an investor a budget you
live by it and you can put clauses in
your financing agreement that say hey if
we come in
under budget i get to keep it or if i
come in under budget let's split what's
left
or you know but i i think whatever you
can pay yourself if you're raising the
money you're creating the content you're
creating jobs for
you know and break even 125 people
you know get what you can you know
because you're going to give the money
back to your investors i trust
so you may never see another dime you
know
so i i never try to tell people what
they should or shouldn't pay themselves
i just say
if you were the investor of the film and
you your filmmaker was being paid what
you're paying yourself would you feel
comfortable looking would you
would you would you be okay looking at
those books and i think if you can
answer yes
that's fine i've never had an investor
i've never had an investor ask me in 30
years of raising independent money how
much i'm paying myself i've had their
lawyer ask me once
one time i had a lawyer ask me and i've
never been asked since
and i was very direct with the lawyer at
the time i belonged to four unions
and i said well i'm a union member
for the following guilds i will be doing
all four of these jobs on the film
i am not going to be taking my union
rates i have parked my union membership
so i could do this project
this is what i normally get paid here's
what i'm doing it for
and he was like wow okay i just he was
like i just didn't know
i thought he was questioning my value he
just was curious
but i i say you know you're going to be
you know every film is a love affair
you're going to walk away from it
scarred
heartbroken chipped teeth black guys
gray bald fat
thin it's it's going to it's going to do
this to you you know you're going to
lose 20 pounds in pre-production you're
going to put on a few pounds during
production and you're going to put on 25
pounds of post
you know so i i just say you know be
fair to yourself
realize that this is going to be
probably a year to an 18-month process
and what is your time worth
and uh don't bankrupt the project
because you have to be greedy or get
paid
you don't budget yourself accordingly
you're a line item you know every job
you do is a line item if you
if you're writing a script you're you
should be paid as a writer if you're
producing you should be paid as a
producer if you're directing it the same
and editing it the same
if you're supervising music and doing
post-production and deliverables that
cost
somebody's gotta get paid to do it right
so which production taught you the most
you don't have to name names or the name
of the movie
or who you work with but it just taught
you the most whether it was
something about yourself whether it was
something about
how you were working with people
something where it changed you in a lot
of ways
could be for better or worse
i you know i grew up as you know
doing independent shoestring
thread budgets with my dad i mean we
were doing
we were doing films that had million
dollar budgets for 20 grand
back in the day when we were shooting in
film and
i learned so you have to learn so much
if you're going to make it work i mean
we literally did these films on crews of
three to five
so you could be shooting a camera
and you could be also holding a boom
pole and mixing an fp32 mixer on your
hip
as you're trying to pull focus and shoot
and you kind of become those you know
those musicians that wear the
symbols underneath and the bass drum and
the tambourine on their head and
you kind of do a lot of that i think i
got shape doing those
the first major film i produced was a 12
million
film from miramax back in the day and
it was frustrating because i knew how to
do so much and wasn't allowed
but what was really cool when we got
there i still got to do so much i'd
co-written a script
and i'd produced the film was one of the
producers of the film
and before we were done i ended up
doubling for one of the big stars
i ended up cutting the film and ended up
being you know working with the post
supervisors and the music supervisors
and
i got to do a lot of things again and
that was really fun and i
it reminded me that
you know when you work in big
budgetville it's funny there's people to
do everything
you know it's spread out so much
but i come from a a place where
everybody did it so much and i i like
when everybody does so much and what's
funny is after living in covid
going back to work where the demands or
the crews are smaller
the people who know how to do much are
the ones who are going to be called
because i know when we're crewing up for
this new film that we're gearing up to
do
everybody's got to be able to do a lot
of things i mean even my camera
operators
they got to be able to do a lot of
things you know my my it's no longer
hair makeup and wardrobe and props it's
one person who's gonna handle all four
of those
it's the only way it's gonna work you
know and uh so
i learned from everything every
production i've ever done
karen i learned from and i
i appreciate each experience i learned
something new on every show
what's the worst piece of advice you've
received and it actually turned out to
be true
but at the time when you heard it you
thought i'm not listening to this person
worst piece of advice i ever got that
turned out to be true
i think the worst advice i ever got
that turned out to be true was um was
something that my photo teacher taught
me in my senior year in high school mr
ken nealy
he uh he called me in after class one
day and he said i'm worried about your
future
he said you're a jack of all trade
master of none
and i said what do you mean he said well
you're here in photo class you're doing
okay you take a decent picture because
you race dirt bikes
you play drums in a band and you've won
an emmy already
what's your plan dude like you gotta
like
and i got really concerned about that
and i gave up a lot of things in my life
because of that
and what's weird is i don't know if that
was bad advice but it was true
and i didn't listen to the advice
and i just became this guy that did a
lot of things
that i i do well enough to to work
and to stay relevant am i a great
storyteller
no am i a great director that's putting
the world on their on their ear
no not reinventing the wheel am i a
great editor that's gonna
you know come up with a way to cut a
film differently than anybody else has
no
so i'm not able to put all of my energy
into one thing
i am really glad now that i'm almost 50
i've been able to stay working for as
long as i have because
i did become a jack of all trade
i don't think if i if if i had listened
to his advice and not pumped the brakes
after a year and a half of getting rid
of everything in my life that was
important to me i would have truly
learned the craft
of everything i could so i know that's
not
the answer to the question you asked but
that is the one thing that has
constantly haunted me over the years was
the advice
did i do it right what did i give up and
then how did i reboot myself and then i
look later and i go well i've
i've actually been i'm i'm okay
so you know did you tell other people
about that conversation and and
did they steer you away from doing too
much
it's funny every time i start a film
everybody tells me you do too much we're
going to be here to support you
you do too much we're going to take a
lot of it off you
and i don't know if it's me
not truly embracing and trusting the
people i work with enough to
to trust that that's gonna happen or
it's going to be okay
um i'm not a control freak
i'm very hands on but i've also been
around too many productions when people
assume somebody's going to take care of
something and
it's just it's unacceptable when they
fall through the cracks
and i'm just somebody that knows if i
handle it it won't
doesn't mean i'm perfect it doesn't mean
i'm great it just means that i know if
it's on my list to do's it's
i i know if it's on my list of to do's
it's going to get done
and i'm very hard to trust people with
doing those things so
um again i don't know if i'm answering
your question
properly but you know i
i have spent my entire career being told
by people well we just want you to
direct and we just want you to deal with
this and
i haven't been able to do that because
you know i haven't felt
that i haven't had the peace in my heart
to do that and i wish i had and it's
nothing anybody has done
it's it's my own problem it's not
somebody has dropped the ball or let me
down it's
that fear it's waking up at two in the
morning as i talk about in the book when
in a sweat scared to death the wrong
actor is going to show up tomorrow
scared to death
we didn't get a permit scared to death
that we didn't order the drone or
whatever
and i know if i'm handling it it's not
going to fall to the cracks
but it sounds like too you love to be
busy i do you know
ambidextrous you're always doing things
adhd but same difference right
or gemini yeah so you just certain
people just love to be
they they just have certain ways about
them they love to be busy i love to be
busy i'd love not to be as busy as i am
but i always find that i'm never not i'm
never still
i'm never still and i always say i'm
gonna stop taking things on and then
three days go by and i'm sitting here
looking at four other projects that i
just committed to get involved with
what was i thinking but somehow some way
they get done
yeah you know yeah i mean i think just
certain people are hardwired differently
i am definitely hardwired differently
but no i mean not in a bad way
yeah just wanting to to say are they
they like they have a tv show on
they're cleaning something over here
they're looking at twitter there's just
yeah just some people i don't vacation
well i don't i don't take days off i
don't vacation luckily my wife is kind
of
we love our little world and what we do
and there's not we're not people that
take two weeks every year to go do
anything
you know we take day trips once every
week or every other week
go do fun things we're always together i
mean we both work from home so
we're together all the time so we have
our time together but
i never oh my god i gotta get away and
go to hawaii or i need to
jump on a plane and go somewhere you
know i just never been in my dna
no cruises no god no
you